helping our wounded warriors find their
inner strength through a crossfit gym
yeah branded one crossfit is the first
and really only non-profit gym in las
vegas offering free memberships to
veterans while they work out with the
community victoria saha takes us through
their mission when we come across a
veteran we often say thank you for your
service but at branded one crossfit
veterans are being offered more than
just a thanks they're offered a free gym
membership the welcoming and the
atmosphere in here is what
made me want to come back here edward
haynes was in the marine corps for 20
years finding his way back to civilian
life wasn't the easiest keeping kind of
a community
has been
beneficial in keeping some of my sanity
you know finding michael like-minded
individuals in a place other than a than
a like a bar crossfit is a form of
high-intensity training haynes says it
reminds him of the brotherhood he felt
trying to accomplish a goal with other
marines when serving knowing that we're
going to share
some of the struggle again
you know
because struggle brings about a lot of
camaraderie are these your favorite
exercises
goodness
all right let's go haynes lets me join
in on a session along with equipment the
gym has soldier boots right at the
entrance and an american flag proudly
hanging adding to the welcome for those
who served what we want to do is get
them out of the house get them doing
something that's productive getting out
of their heads releases a lot of stress
and it helps you feel better
and that carries on for several hours
after you're done studies show since
2001 114 thousand vets have died by
suicide a scary statistic but branded
one is hoping to give our service men
and women another mission in life
besides carrying the weight of the
country it's not just about them though
right it's about bringing just regular
community members into the gym so that
hopefully they can just feel like
they're a part of a normal community
disabled or not the gym has a spot
waiting for any veteran
victoria saha live local now